After cutters were looking for stomach ulcer help.
The cause of this could be because of recently added medications,
can hydrochloric acid with meals have an adverse effect and cause pain.
Any thoughts if using castoropac over stomach would be helpful in other tips.
Okay, so if you take HCl and it causes pain,
that's a real good chance. So if you're not tolerant to HCl because of pain,
real good chance you already have stomach damage or you have an ulcer,
you have an active ulcer. You have to back off and go to acetic acid,
so taking apple cider vinegar. You need to acidify the stomach because
it's the lack of acid in the stomach that has caused the ulcer because
never ulcers are caused from Hpylora. He'll go back to Pylora.
And he'll go back to Pylora is caused because a decreased stomach acid
9 times 10. So if you had proper stomach acid in the first place, never would have
got Hpylora, never would have got a stomach ulcer. So you got to back up and do
that. But going right to HCl causing irritation, you may have to heal the stomach
first. Go to our website, cuttersclinics.co.nz,
ursclinic.com, search Hpylora, or he'll go back to Pylora.
I have a whole sequence of events and videos on how to do this correctly.
If you have adverse reaction to HCl, you start with
apple cider vinegar. If you can't even tolerate apple cider vinegar, you got to
heal the stomach in the first place. And you could use things like
we talked about before, deglycerized, lick brush. You could use
okra, you could use glutamate, you could use, so we have a product called
clear GI that can be helpful. It's a powdered form.
You got to heal the stomach. You got to take a few weeks to heal the stomach or
it's not always stomach. It's the commodity too. You could have ulceration even in the
hospital, so all the tested elsewhere. So you got to heal the gut.
And then you keep trying tolerance to apple cider vinegar, tell you could
tolerate that with the meal. And then you add, then you're tolerating
to find a couple of tables with apple cider vinegar prior to meal.
Then you try HCl and you have to up the doses of HCl.
And I share a video on how to do that. So that will help you walk through that
pathway to try to heal your gut, rebalance your hydrochloric acid production
and your stomach. And to eventually work out, kill it, HCl.
I use it. We have a product called ParaClear. We have
Burberry products out there that can be extremely helpful to kill HCl.
Remember with HCl, it's best that everybody in the family takes
Burberry or ParaClear product. Maybe they don't have to take the same
dosage as you do, but it's something good to take. I personally take Burberry
all the time. I take ParaClear not every day, but at least once a week,
because HCl is just everywhere. In HCl, Laura, we said it causes
stomach ulcers and issues, but it is also the number one cause of stomach
cancer, worldwide. And it goes systemic. It is the cause of rosacea.
It's a cause of a lot of skin rashes that go undiagnosed. It's the cause of,
it's one of the top four causes of coronary heart disease.
So H by Laura, it's under the endothelial layer. That's the
single layer of epithelial cells that coat the inside of your arteries.
If it's underneath that endothelial layer and can attack the smooth muscles,
it can be the major player of high blood pressure. And it is definitely a major
player and etching of the arteries along with whole assisted and causes
cholesterol patching. So cholesterol gets the
they be named the bad guy, but it's actually H by Laura.
That is commonly the root cause and you need to address that.